qué determina nuestra inteligencia una
corriente de pensamiento dice que tal
vez simplemente nacemos con ella o la
tienes o no algunas personas son
inteligentes otras no tanto pero tal vez
eso se pueda cambiar y resulta que se ha
hecho mucha investigación sobre esto en
las últimas décadas y la respuesta es
muy clara que la inteligencia de hecho
se puede cambiar lo que hemos aprendido
lo que nos han enseñado los
investigadores es que nuestros cerebros
se parece mucho a un músculo sabemos que
podemos hacer crecer los músculos yendo
al gimnasio haciendo ejercicio y
forzando los músculos no hace solo
ejercicios que sean fáciles para tus
músculos haces que tus músculos se
esfuercen y se ejerciten y así ellos se
reconstruyen y se hacen más fuertes
hacer este esfuerzo es una señal para
que tu cuerpo mande más recursos a esa
parte del cuerpo y vemos qué pasa lo
mismo con el cerebro y aquí hay un par
de ejemplos de eso el primero muestra
como el cerebro humano se desarrolla en
la infancia temprana es una imagen
de las neuronas del cerebro al nacer y
conforme el niño crece interactúa con su
ambiente intenta cosas se esfuerza se
esfuerza por hablar conversar
interactuar con otros y entender el
mundo a su alrededor y conforme se
esfuerza vemos que a los 6 años hay
conexiones más fuertes y profundas entre
las neuronas
similar similarmente perdón si me
trabajo estas son imágenes de neuronas
en dos ambientes distintos estas son las
neuronas de animales que estaban en
ambientes que no los estimula van que no
interactúan con otros animales están
solo en una jaula y este es el cerebro
de un animal que si está en un ambiente
estimulante que tiene retos constantes
que todo el tiempo tiene nuevos
estímulos
así que el gran descubrimiento de toda
esta investigación es que claro que si
puedes cambiar tu inteligencia el
cerebro es como un músculo mientras más
lo usas más fuerte se vuelve y que la
mejor manera de hacerlo no es con cosas
fáciles eso puede que ayude un poquito
pero lo que realmente ayuda al cerebro
es cuando te esfuerzas por algo y de
hecho la investigación demuestra que el
cerebro crece más no cuando respondes
bien una pregunta sino cuando te
equivocas y así al menos para mí esto es
muy emocionante porque me dice que
cuando estoy intentando algo y me
enfrento al menos con un poco de
dificultad es un poco de frustración
puedo sentirme bien porque sé que de
hecho es cuando más estoy creciendo esto
no es sólo algo que digo para animar la
investigación demuestra que cuando
cometes errores cuando le pones retos a
tu cerebro y revisas porque estabas
equivocado y procesas la información es
cuando tu cerebro crece más así que si
sigues haciéndolo vas a tener un cerebro
más fuerte más hábil y supongo que
podríamos decir más inteligente